[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire sur le plaisir de recevoir
aujourd'hui ovidie pour son nouveau
livre baiser après me to avec des
illustrations de digues les c'est une
sorte de guide du bon comportement pour
une sexualité apaisée plus égalitaire et
donc plus joyeuse
on va voir ce que ça donne je reçois
également le réalisateur de poissons
sexe un film de science fiction qui sort
demain en salles c'est olivier babinet
il est avec son conseiller scientifique
georges de brega ce et enfin luc perino
le dr luc perino pour son ouvrage
patient zéro c'est une histoire un
verset de la médecine pas celle des
médecins pour une fois mais celle des
malades qui ont permis aux médecins de
devenir célèbre en découvrant de
nouvelles maladies et donc commence
comme d'habitude par notre époque qu'est
ce qui caractérise ce début de xxième
siècle voici votre réponse en images
vidéo commence par la vôtre vient
d'apparaître elle est très jolie alors
on a dû un tout petit peu la censure et
il se trouve que cette jeune femme est
le sexe ouvert et à la télévision n'a
pas le droit de montrer à sexe féminin
ouvert on n'a pas droit non plus montré
un sexe masculin en érection
mais je vous écoute pourquoi cette image
et et que représente-t-elle mais alors
je croyais qu'il était interdit nat et
intervenants oui mais sérieusement il ya
la loi et puis surtout dans sur cette
chaîne on est particulièrement surveillé
je peux vous dire très bien non mais
alors donc en fait cette photo c'est une
photo de la performance de deborah de
roberty ce au musée d'orsay qui
s'appelait un miroir de l'origine donc
effectivement on la voit les jambes
écartées devant l'origine du monde
est ce que je trouve très intéressant
dans cette performance c'est qu'à ce
moment là elle avait fait de comment
dire du corps de la femme comme objet
regard des objets regardant c'est à dire
elle avait donné vie aux modèles déjà
lui avait donné un visage et surtout
elle s'était posée une gopro sur le
front ou être filmé donc le visiteur est
ce qui était assez intéressant à mon
sens c'est que à l'inversé ce regard est
posée la question de coût sont les
femmes ne rendant les musées est ce
qu'ils sont sur les tableaux ou est-ce
qu'elles sont sur le cartel et en
produisant à elle même de l'image en
regardant le spectateur elles produisent
elles mêmes de la ré inverser ce regard
là
et donc cette performance à date de 2014
mais je la trouve plus que jamais
d'actualité
par rapport à tout ce qui peut se passer
à l'heure actuelle dans le monde du
cinéma entre autres où tout à coup en
fait un certain nombre même d'actrice à
ce qui a été par ailleurs mon chemin à
un moment ce d'actrice sont passés de
l'autre côté de la caméra en produisant
elle même de l'image et en posant et
même un regard sur le monde et je trouve
que c'est c'est plus que jamais
d'actualité depuis nitoo entre autres
enfin voilà cette question-là du regard
et du passage de l'objet à ce sujet je
la trouve intéressante
olivier babinet le réalisateur votre
image à vous la voici
alors de quoi s'agit-il c'est un robot
dans un parc à singapour qui est là pour
contrôler les gens et leur demander de
respecter la distanciation sociale et
c'est un robot qui est développé par
boston dynamics qui est une société
américaine qui je me suis intéressé
parce que j'ai commencé à travailler à 9
ans sur mon fils et comme j'avais un
personnage de roboticiens n est que je
voulais intégrer des véritables robots
dans le film je me suis intéressé à ce
que faisait cette société qui
complètement hallucinant et un peu
effrayant j'avais un ami qui m'avait
fait découvrir sa et qui me disait tu
imagines le jour où ou leur chien
viendra de chercher chez toi parce que
pour te contrôler ou pour et puis
finalement le temps a passé neuf ans se
sont écoulés et on a fini par voir cette
image dans la réalité
et voilà alors j'ai pas pu collaborer
avec eux pour mon film malheureusement
mais on a créer nos propres robots mais
mais qu'on voulait assez réaliste
georges de breguet est ce votre email
j'avoue c'est une courbe alors c'est une
courbe de court alors sur une série de
courbes
donc c'est une série s'est scellée
fonction exponentielle
donc c'est une esthétique toute relative
mais je crois que dans l'époque actuelle
c'est une course qui est en train de
devenir importance avec les les
épidémies suivent des lois exponentielle
en phase épidémique ce nombre de cas en
fonction du temps mais c'est aussi le
sait aussi les courbes qui vont décrire
par exemple
l'activité d'un matériau fissile ans
dans une roue ou l'augmentation de la
consommation des ressources ou
l'augmentation de l'accumulation de
richesses des personnes les plus riches
d'une société donc c'est les courbes qui
sont qui sont importantes et qui ont
cette propriété d'être un peu difficile
a ensuite essayé on a on a du mal à
partir de la gauche de la courbe où tout
semble aller très bien à imaginer la
catastrophe qui vient c'est la courbe de
la catastrophe à venir
c'est pas une courbe dont les humains
sont je pense ont spontanément habitué à
anticiper l'avenir donc ça suppose un
niveau d'abstraction important et donc
choix que politiquement c'est une
question comment est ce qu'on fait pour
prendre des décisions politiques face à
des processus qui suivent ce type de loi
on l'a vu avec le co lead comment est ce
qu'on met en place un confinement quand
on a que 40 ou 50 personnes malades mais
qu'on sait que dans une quinzaine de
jours y en aura 4000 ou 5000 et comment
est ce qu'on fait pour agir sur le
réchauffement climatique quand on voit
pas les six nous on n'en voit que les
prémices voilà donc je crois que c'est
des cours auxquels on va avoir à faire
de plus en plus et qui pose des
questions politiques
il s'appelle manière il va falloir aussi
apprendre à les lire ses courbes parce
que tout dépend de la graduation
on peut faire monter une courbe exane
est aucun sens quand il y avait un
malade du coc vide si le lendemain il y
en avait 4 évidemment la courbe
augmenter considérablement
mais ça faisait quand même que ça que
malade à la fin ça n'était pas 5000
j'espère aller milliards alors vous avez
il faut apprendre à lire mais justement
les courbes exponentielle certaine
manière si vous décalez lax un peu si
vous projetez une semaine après
finalement ça change pas grand chose
c'est à dire que la catastrophe arrive à
une distance n'est pas très différente
par exemple si vous prenez la france et
l'italie pendant un temps au début du
mois de mars
on avait huit jours d'écart sur les
progressions ça veut dire que huit jours
après au niveau de l'italie
mais les italiens étaient déjà dans la
catastrophe que nous on vivait
tranquillement sans savoir que huit
jours plus tard on serait confinée en
fait les physiciens par exemple savait
déjà qu'on serait confinée dans les
laboratoires les gens savaient déjà
qu'on serait confinée huit ou dix jours
avant parce que la progression était
clairement exponentielle et donc on
pouvait se projeter
mais évidemment ça suppose et c'est là
où c'est difficile c'est que ça suppose
une compréhension mathématiques parce
que l'intuition ne peut pas
choses et dont je crois qu'il ya
derrière et aussi la question de la
culture mathématique et physique et
c'est une question qui était difficile
luc perino je vous annonce c'est un
c'est une sorte de slogan un
rappelez-nous qu il s'agit alors j'ai
pris moselle beurre donc c'est
l'abréviation de moustache de novembre
c'est une association qui s'appelle
mauvaises moeurs et qui a créé mouvement
pour donner suite à octobre rose vous
savez octobre rose c'est le dépistage du
cancer du sein et les hommes sans doute
ceux souffrant privé en reste et ils ont
créé moustache de novembre pour faire de
la publicité pour le dépistage du cancer
de la prostate alors j'ai pris ça parce
que c'est l'aspect le plus grotesque et
le plus comique sans doute de la
surmédicalisation et du dépistage de
masse puisque pour le dépistage du
cancer de la prostate par le ps entre
autres qui est le plus connu
presque tous les pays de l' ocde des
conseils ce dépistage qui est non
seulement inutile mais qui peut être
même peut-être un peu dangereux en tout
cas inutile complètement mais malgré
cela malgré que les ministères dont des
pays de la cedeao le déconseille même
chez les personnes à risque
eh bien ces associations vivent en eau
libre et font de la promotion
disons qu'ils sont moins en décalage
avec les recommandations puisque encore
beaucoup de pays recommande le dépistage
du cancer du sein
même si avec commencé à abandonner pour
la prostate c'est presque l'unanimité
c'est un dépistage génétique les aspects
de la surmédicalisation m'amuse beaucoup
et on peut supposer que derrière ce
genre d'association il ya une ribambelle
de conflit d'intérêt je peux pas le dire
exactement mais souvent ces associations
de patients sont supportés par la grande
industrie sanitaires et bien commençons
[Musique]
ovidie vous publiez baiser après mitu
aux éditions mare à bulles avec des
illustrations de digues les deux très
jolies illustrations il des films très
très bien les gens sont particulièrement
beaux et sexy en dépit du fait que ce
soit des dessins humoristiques
vous pensez vraiment qu'un tel mouvement
qui dénonçaient des cas de harcèlement
d'agressions de viol va modifier notre
façon à la fois de séduire et de faire
l'amour moi j'ai la sensation que ça
beaucoup rebattu les cartes jusque dans
notre chambre à coucher en fait j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya énormément de
sujets qui peuvent paraître et des
sujets annexes comme je sais pas
l'éducation des garçons des petites
filles peu importe la charge mentale
enfin voilà plein de sujets dont on a
parlé céda ces deux trois dernières
années va depuis octobre 2017
j'ai l'impression que le fait de mettre
tous ces sujets là sur la table ont
quand même beaucoup considérablement
rebattu les cartes des rapports hommes
femmes
et forcément ça a eu un impact sur notre
comportement sexuel sur notre façon le
baiser et surtout par exemple avec
toutes les questions autour du
consentement on n'a jamais autant parlé
de consentement que ces deux dernières
années enfin trois dernières années
d'ailleurs
enfin voilà donc oui je pense je pense
que ça modifie beaucoup puis surtout il
ya toute une génération qui est arrivé
donc ces trois dernières années qui a
grandit aussi en utilisant ces concepts
là ces concepts de consentement ces
concepts aussi de sotchi ming par
exemple qu'il ya un terme pour désigner
tout ce qui est discrimination
ostracisation des jeunes filles ou des
femmes pour leur sexualité et concepts
de même mon à part on parle de revenge
port il ya plein de choses comme ça dont
on parlait pas forcément avant et dont
on parle aujourd'hui
et moi j'ai l'impression que pour cette
génération là déjà ça ça change des
choses et grandissent avec des idées
peut-être plus je passais plus
égalitaire en tout cas plus respectueuse
et il ya une autre génération qui est
aussi la mienne en fait moi j'ai 40 ans
j'ai eu 40 ans ya quelques jours vous ne
souhaitez gérer cet anniversaire vous
ferai mais voilà j'ai eu 40 ans il ya
quelques jours et ni moi ils ne sont que
ma génération à moi elle s'est retrouvés
un moment face à un grand vide
pourtant mais moi qui baigne un peu dans
toutes ces histoires de féminisme toute
l'année au moment de nous tous et même
degree qui est donc les distraits
l'illustratrice on s'est posé la
question de
mais comment on fait comment est-ce
qu'on va réussir à d et maintenant et
c'est d'ailleurs c'est peut-être un des
seuls points communs des seuls d'accord
qui a pu y avoir entre les
antiféministes à ce moment là il est
féministe elle même c'est qu'il ya eu
cette question on s'est dit mais mais
comment est-ce qu'on a baissé maman
comment ce que ça va être possible parce
que finalement ça remet tellement de
choses en question dans les rapports
homme femme et moi je dis son ensemble
ont tué moi il ya eu un moment où je me
suis dit j'y arriverai pu et diglee
aussi elle le raconte je me permets de
le dire parce qu'elle nous raconte en
dessin dans baisers après me to hell
même pendant un an a fait ceinture parce
qu'il a dit mais qu'est ce que je fais à
partir de maintenant parce qu'on sera
forcément on se repose la question de la
provenance de nos fantasmes de se dire
tiens par exemple si jamais être soumise
tout ça vient et c est ce que c'est une
construction culturelle et 60
constructions sociales
est-ce que c'est mon expérience est ce
que c'est juste si enfin voilà donc
c'est ça remet plein de trucs en
question c'est ça peut poser des
nouvelles questions aussi c'est pas
tellement
alors je pense qu'il y en a quand même
qui ont continué de faire l'amour
continué de séduire l'amour il ya des il
ya des questions inédites par exemple si
on voit ça souvent dans les films
vous savez le garçon qui se retrouve
avec un transsexuel mine ces pacs est un
transsexuel il procure une très jolie
femme il se laisse draguer et puis au
moment où il découvre ta transsexuels il
s'enfuit et je me suis dit à ce moment
est-ce que ça n'est pas de la
discrimination par exemple est-ce que le
transsexuels en question ne peut pas
dire après c'est de la discrimination
vous en aviez envie avant maintenant je
n'en avais plus envie c'est bien vous me
discriminer veiller à de nouvelles
questions qui se posent et vous rendre
répondait un certain nombre par yves ya
beaucoup de gens qui dit on va plus
pouvoir draguer pour ce qu'on va pouvoir
toujours draguer quand même je pense
qu'on a toujours pouvoir continuer à
draguer à se séduire et puis et puis à
faire l'amour je le souhaite et je me
souhaite aussi quelque part quand je dis
ça je sais pas j'ai pas encore envie de
fermer boutique quelque part donc
évidemment qu'il ya des il ya plein de
nouvelles questions qui se posaient sur
notre façon de nous approcher les uns
les autres
ben de toute façon je suis pas sûr que
la drague à l'ancienne la drague à la
papa comme ça je suis pas sûr qu'elle
aboutisse et réellement sûr de la
relation sur du rapport sexuel
franchement j'y crois pas trop je
moi pas que un patron qui fasse des
blagues graveleuses à sa secrétaire il
pouvait réellement espérer avoir de la
relation et je crois pas qu'un type dans
la rue qui va vous harcelez dans le bus
où nous dire que on al'air je
crois pas qu'ils attendent réellement de
la relation enfin donc oui je pense
qu'on va continuer à se draguer mais par
exemple est ce qu'on peut continuer à
être galant vous posez la question aussi
puisque on sait bien qu'à partir du
moment où on paye le vert nous les
hommes on paye le dîner on peut
soupçonner qu on attend en échange une
relation sexuelle de même quand on vous
tient la porte
c'est une façon de rompre l'égalité
entre les sexes alors est-ce que ça ça
pourrait devenir mal vu alors je suis
pas un spécialiste de la galanterie donc
j'ai pas vraiment d'avis au complètement
arrêtée sur la question maintenant on va
dire la galanterie quelque part dans son
origine c'est une forme de sexisme
bienveillance c'est à dire je te je peux
bien de payer la disent qu'ils vont
tenir la porte aussi à côté voilà je te
fais subir d'autres discriminations au
quotidien dans la société donc voilà on
va dire ça peut voilà je suis pas hyper
emballé par la galanterie non ce que je
pointe du doigt dans cette lettre la ce
que je raconte en fait puisqu'il est
question de comment dire de d'attentes
de paiement en nature
en gros ce que je raconte c'est un
cadeau qui m'est fait et la personne en
face qui s'offusquent de ne pas avoir de
rapports sexuels en retour c'est là
c'est la stratégie du don et du contre
don ou les anthropologues nous explique
que sa gouverne les rapports entre les
hommes et les femmes depuis l'origine
des temps c'est une forme d'échangé
économico sexuel sauf qu'il n'est pas
consenti
moi j'ai rien contre le principe des
changes économico sexuel si les règles
sont posés à l'avance c'est à dire dans
le cadre par exemple de la prostitution
les règles sont fixées c'est à dire tu
obtiendras du rapport sexuels contre de
l'argent contre tel prix qui est fixé là
la question que ça pose c c'est
finalement c'est l'histoire du cadeau
non consenti et c'est ce que j'observe
vont avec de plus en plus de jeunes
femmes par exemple quand elle drague sur
steam d'heure c'est qu'à la fin si ça va
pas elle insiste pour séparer en deux la
note du rosé quoi en groupe c'est à dire
pour être sûr de ne pas avoir
à devoir quelque chose en échange de
l'ordre justement de du du sexuel donc
voilà c'est cette question là que ça
pose maintenant j'ai pas de réponse
ferme et définitive sur la galanterie
j'ai nommé voyez pas s'arrêter là de
votre liste maintenant quand même quoi
l'intérêt de votre livre qui est écrit
sous forme de lettre que vous envoyez à
vos ex l'intérêt du livre c'est que
justement vous nous faites vous les
pointer du doigt un certain nombre de
questions qu'il faut qu'on se pose
il y en a certaines que vous ne posez
pas d'ailleurs j'ai envie de vous poser
quand même par exemple on a bien compris
depuis la sphère louis siquet qu'on n'a
pas le droit de sortir son sexe devant
une femme qui a pas forcément envie de
le regarder encore moins de se masturber
devant ted c'est une
c'est du harcèlement sexuel mais elle
est une femme qui soulèveraient son
pull-over et nous montrer ses seins par
exemple est ce qu'on a le droit de
porter plainte pour agression pour
harcèlement pas donc c'est pas une
agression il ne nous a pas touchés c'est
du harcèlement alors je suis pas
spécialiste de la loi je peux à vos
cannes mais je suppose que oui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une petite
attention qu'ils arrêtent de nous
montrer leurs seins par provocation
ça dépend ce qu'on peut montrer ses
seins dans un contexte politique c'est
totalement voyez des mourad de roberty
c'est ce qu'elle a fait dans sa
performance ou d'été en marianne on l'a
vu avec les femen on l'a vu tout le
voilà la nudité politique elle existe
aussi l est pas nécessairement sexuelle
d'ailleurs mais non je pense qu'une des
formes les plus classiques d'exhibition
non consenti on va dire voilà
aujourd'hui c'est la digue pic s'est
concrètement c'est ça c'est le fait de
recevoir des photos de beats sur des
réseaux sociaux sur sa messagerie des
photos non consenti c'est vachement
intéressant quand même le ce que ça
raconte la digue pic moi je n ai pas que
j'en ai reçu pendant des années j'avais
cru à une époque que c'était parce que
je traitais des questions de sexualité
pornographie et que donc quelque part
c'était ma croix à porter est en fête
avec le développement des réseaux
sociaux
je me suis rendu compte auprès de jeunes
femmes et de jeunes garçons aussi qu'il
recevait en masse qu'ils et elles
recevaient en masse donc des diptyques
comme ça
et je trouve ça vachement intéressant
parce que personne aucun commentaire
aucun garçon ne m'a jamais dit moi j'ai
déjà reçu une politique genre ben
j'étais sur twitter et dans mes messages
privés tout à coup j'ai reçu une photo
d'une parfaite inconnue
la chatte écarté voilà ça ça n'arrive
jamais jamais personne ne me l'a dit
donc voilà en fait la question pourrait
se poser aussi c'est comment ça se fait
que voilà que l' inverse soit beaucoup
beaucoup moins fréquentes et que
beaucoup les deux jeunes femmes de
femmes reçoivent des dites piquer deux
jeunes garçons aussi parce qu'avec les
garçons ont tendance à montrer leur sexe
les femmes - mais les temps les femmes
ont tendance à montrer leurs seins et
les hommes
ils n'ont pas besoin puisque toute façon
le droit de les montrer quand il quand
ils veulent
c'est c'est blanche gardin qui avait
posé cette question aux césars et et il
ya d'ailleurs très jolies illustrations
de diglee représentant blanche gardin
elle a demandé est ce qu on a bien
compris que les réalisateurs et les
producteurs n'ont plus droit de violer
les actrices mais est-ce que les
actrices peuvent encore couché pour
avoir un rôle une question qu'elle
impose et qui a fait rire pas tout le
monde d'ailleurs je me suis avec le le
public de la cérémonie des plus torrides
jaune mais subit déjà lesquelles
personne n'a répondu pour l'instant vous
non plus d'ailleurs
je me souviens effectivement je crois
que c'est l actrice de grave
il me semble qu'ils avaient qui avait
une réaction favola clip qui avait pas
rit à cet effet un prix là moi moi j'ai
rien personnellement quand j'ai écouté
blanche gardin ce jour là après cette
histoire de d'obtenir un rôle contre
contre une coucherie c'est c'est quelque
chose qui est autorisé je dirais par un
système qui est dénoncée justement par
ba plus tôt par le féminisme justement
c'est un système qui devrait pas exister
c'est c'est celui de ne pas être reconnu
pour son travail à sa juste valeur et
d'obtenir une gratification ou
d'escaladé les échelons par par la
coucherie bon voilà c'est c'est
évidemment un système qui est comment
dire c'est une pratique qui inclut dans
un système qui est beaucoup plus vaste
et qui est à mon sens reste à détruire
mais donner enfin moi je ne suis pas
emballé par le fait de
tony connaît aussi quelques traits
beaucoup plus du cinéma où on a même
épousé le réalisateur et dans ces cas-là
ça installe la relation et ça a donné
très beau film parfois le consentement
puisqu'il sort par lui et vous en
parlait beaucoup des nations je ne sais
pas je ne suis pas sûr je suis pas sûr
que je sais pas si on regarde domaine
jeu par godard et anna karina et même le
film qu'ils avaient fait au moment de
leur séparation où justement il ya qui
est un peu votre ville est ce que
c'était une crème marié où elle est
partie couché avec roanne et je n'ai pas
l'impression mois que c'était comment
dire une forme de domination que
macarena cemac et avec tu es juste pour
obtenir des rôles toi je pense que c'est
plus complexe que ça encore des
histoires de poe entre réa et et actrice
et will toute façon on sait jamais ce
qui se passe dans l'air dans les led
chambre à coucher des gens donc c'est
très difficile d'avoir un avis sur le
sujet le consentement vous y pensez vous
en parler doit-il être explicité réitéré
tout au long de l'acte sexuel comme
certains le craignent
en tout cas à chaque nouvelle position
est ce qu'il faut redemander
est ce que je peux en fait j'ai beaucoup
entendu après nous tous cette idée que
[Musique]
presse qu'il allait falloir signé un
contrat il y avait eu cette espèce de
légende urbaine autour d'une application
suédoise où il fallait cocher à l'avance
oui je consens at elle rapporté rapporté
un rapport ce qui est débile parce qu'on
peut consentir avant le rapport à
quelque chose je dirais bien appuyé sur
l'instant voilà ne plus avoir envie
donc c'était complètement débile mais il
ya beaucoup de gens qui ont dit oh là là
s'il faut demander le consentement de
l'autre ça pas pu être excitant c'est
pas une demande écrite formelle hein
c'est juste au fur et à mesure du
rapport est attentif aux attentes il
veut à l'autre lui demander une fois
temps en temps juste un ça va
même un ça va même entre deux mots
obscènes ça reste quand même un vrai
cela et il ne semble pas que ça fasse
des bandes ennemies ni face à kas
l'excitation radicalement c'est juste
s'assurer qu'on n'est pas pour reprendre
l'expression vergine despentes qu'on
n'est pas en train de baiser seul l ai
dit ça à propos des hommes et 10 les
hommes pendant un très long temps a pris
à dstl mais il ya quelque chose qui est
un peu de cet ordre là bas c'est cesser
de baisers seul
juste regarder l'autre et vérifier que
tout va bien et que l'autre est bien
d'accord pour ce qui est en train de se
passer
une question mail dans le rapport de
nation pareille à une question que vous
ne l'abordé pas mais qui à mes yeux se
posent depuis mis tous et balances ton
corps c'est que à partir du moment où
une femme votre partenaire a consenti
explicitement à tout ce qui s'est passé
que le lendemain elle vous a même envoyé
un texto pour vous dire qu'elle avait
espéré qu'on allait se revoir très vite
qu'on est même parfois on s'est même
revue on a continué plus de chemins se
sont séparés à quel moment est-ce que je
peux être sûr que je ne l'est pas violer
c'est à dire que qu'est-ce qui m'assure
que dans dix ans moi la vraie porte quel
homme et même peut-être une femme
pourquoi pas ça viendra que dans dix ans
on va pas me dire mais attendez elle
était en état de sidération vous l'avait
violée j'ai pas de jets pas de réponse
claire à ça parce que ça implique
tellement de situations individuelles
compliqué mais j'ai quand même la
sensation que si on ne se rend pas
compte sur l'instant que l'autre est en
état de sidération et que hulu elle est
en train de subir un acte sexuel
c'est qu'il ya un souci quand même c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses en
profondeur à remettre en question moi
j'ai quand même l'impression que l'on en
est là c'est ce que je disais à
l'instant à propos d' apprendre à baiser
seul normalement quand on ne baise pas
seuls on arrive à se rendre compte que
l'autre étant site est en état de
sidération et que quelque chose et que
quelque chose ne fondra ne va pas et
qu'elle n'est pas en état de consentir
après si ccc des règles élémentaires si
l'autre est complètement complètement
bourré ou défoncées bain et vaut mieux
ne pas y aller si enfin voilà est-ce
qu'elle est dans un état normal c'est
les règles vraiment de base j'ai envie
de dire que le pire est qu'il reste à
respecter mais je n'ai pas la sensation
moi qui ai tant de situations dans tous
les viols qui ont été dénoncées qui est
tant de situations où
la personne n'aurait dit oh la la
qu'est-ce que je m'éclate et le
lendemain on aurait dit non mais tu t'es
pas rendu compte que c'était un viol
j'ai pas l'impression que c'est tout le
tout au moment du mouvement mené tous
toutes les situations qui ont été
dénoncées j'ai pas l'impression que
c'était ce genre de situation là qui
revenait quand même il ya eu des cas et
je pense qu'il ya des cas d'ailleurs qui
vont arriver devant la justice et qui
sont plus proches de celui que je
décrivais mais il y en a plein d'autres
vous avez raison vous aborder la
question du des hommes qui y pénètre y
compris leurs femmes d'ailleurs pendant
leur sommeil
mais on n'aborde jamais la question
inverse c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'une
femme pendant qu'un homme dort est-ce
qu'elle a le droit de prendre son sexe
de manipuler de l'embrasser ou même de
l'introduire en elle
on sait bien que les hommes pendant leur
sommeil peuvent avoir une érection est
ce que là est ce que l'époux de la
petite a dit la compagne la maîtresse
d'un soir a le droit de s'emparer du
sexe en érection de son partenaire quand
il dort sur marc parce que j'ai
l'impression d'être là madame de routine
des bons comportements sexuels
ces questions et je trouvais un peu
désemparé moi j'aurais tendance à penser
qu'à partir du moment où une personne
n'est pas en capacité de se rendre
compte de ce qu'est en train de se
passer il vaut mieux pas y aller c'est
la personne dort on n'y va pas c'est
tout ce que vous avez l'air de dire pour
les femmes effectivement donc ça inclut
les hommes aussi bon il ya énormément
d'autres questions vous abordé dans ce
livre une interview comme celle ci
dépasse ans et remplacer les lecture
d'un livre donc baiser on apprenne à
préciser que ce livre s'achève et
également par une lettre d' excuses mais
qui dit lui aussi que j'adresse aux
hommes avec qui je me suis mal comportés
puisque encore une fois je suis pas là
madame de rothschild et vos
comportements sexuels donc je ne crois
pas moi même être exemples de
commentaires de comportements
problématiques donc il ya cédait
d'ailleurs il ya une de vos lettres
d'excusés qui concerne les eaux mais
enfin un homme à qui vous avez reproché
de ne pas avoir d'érection et c'est très
bien le diable voilà aussi ça ça fait
partie des mauvais comportements s'est
reprochée aux coupes qu'il n'ait pas eu
d'érection
le livre gelé
je rappelle paru aux éditions média bull
avec de très jolies illustrations de
diglee
[Musique]
nous voilà maintenant avec olivier
babinet georges de brega ce joli vielles
babinet vous êtes le réalisateur de
poissons sexe un film de science fiction
qui sort demain aux salles avec gustave
kervern dans le rôle principal
vous êtes avec votre conseiller
scientifique georges de brega ce qui est
directeur de recherche au cnrs
le film se passe au moment où les
poissons sont en train de disparaître si
l'histoire d'un chercheur qui veut leur
redonner envie de copuler entre eux
voyez qu'on ne change pas exactement de
sujets c'est une fable sur la fin du
désir ou sur la difficulté de se
reproduire
olivier c'est un mélange des deux je
dirai pas ce que moi quand j'ai commencé
à réfléchir à ce film je voulais avoir
un enfant et j'étais déjà j'avais 40 ans
c'était il ya neuf ans et je voyais
beaucoup de gens autour de moi qui
avaient attendu longtemps à voir pour
avoir un enfant qui avait des problèmes
pour se reproduire qui faisait des fiv
du coup je me documente je découvre que
la qualité du sperme a baissé de 40% à
paris depuis une dizaine d'années donc
je me dis est ce que moi mon sperme va
être que vous continuez à ce qu'il est
ce qu'il va être efficace
et puis en même temps je veux plus je
m'intéresse à ça que je découvre les
dysfonctionnements la sexualité des
poissons due aux rejets médicamenteux
dans l'eau aux projets qui sont les
mêmes que ceux qui nous affectent les
des espèces des mâles qui se féminise et
vice versa les alligators qui ont pénis
qui rétrécit dans certaines régions et
les les adolescents danois dans d'autres
régions aussi statistiquement tout ça
m'angoisse pas mal
du coup ça m'angoisse du coup je me dis
avoir un enfant dans un monde comme ça
oui il ya pas mal de résoudre ses
angoisses et ce qui n'est pas vraiment
arrangé depuis
bref j'étais dans toutes ces questions
là et ça c'est un peu un carnet dans
cette histoire de tous est incarnée dans
ce personnage de physiciens qui étudie
les dysfonctionnements la sexualité des
poissons et qui lui même n'a pas fait
l'amour depuis longtemps et dans un
monde où les poissons ont plus envie et
n'ont plus de désir donc le manque de
désir est devenu une métaphore de une
espèce de de déprime ou de 2 comme les
poissons on arrête finalement ont baissé
les nageoires et les humains soient
entraînées par ce à quoi on cette
déprime généralisée qui a commencé par
les poissons
on va regarder la bande annonce du film
on va voir comment vos pérégrinations
intellectuelle on a quoi ils ont abouti
bell ont abouti à ça m aux territoriales
françaises
[Musique]
quel à daofu je vous rappelle qu'on n'a
pas vu la queue de poisson sur les côtes
françaises depuis deux ans il ya un vrai
pour le montre des poissons faux falloir
parler c'est ton il faut les regarder en
face et les muons mais qui fut l'idée
d'avoir des gosses et toi tu veux
changer des couches poisson merdé avec
ses enfants c'est le mini c'est l'avenir
problème c'est qu'il ya plein de femmes
un bel oiseau 35 ans habitant 50,21 % de
femmes en âge de procréer cas rama yade
tu retires les 7860 qui lui en couple
mamas à faire ça fait 4 la dernière
palette pilotes se dirige vers les côtes
atlantiques
qu'est-ce que cela signifie
vous devez de boire un verre chez soi
[Musique]
août
c'est à quoi tu joues mais laisse tomber
j'ai connu depuis la 6ème on est comme
deux aimants elle et moi je mets et là
il y avait mes piranhas j'ai étudié le
langage des piranhas par exemple qu'un
petit point que leurs matches comme ça
là j'ai envie de faire l'amour
je crois que marco ne s'en sont pas
assez développés la loupe jamais vu une
activité signer pareil
alors qu'est ce que vous faites année
par georges de brega se vous m'avez
l'air d'un drôle de conseillers
scientifiques on entend dans ce film un
poisson par les voulait pas dit que
c'était pas possible ou alors peut-être
que c'est possible
ouais en plus même pas un poisson mais
non je suis j'étais conseiller
scientifique uniquement pour essayer je
crois que
c'est un effort louable de la part
d'olivier d'arriver à montrer et la
recherche d'une manière un peu différent
de ce qu'on voit souvent au cinéma ou
laboratoires de recherche rassemble des
espèces de cockpit de l'airbus ou tout
est parfait clean et là on voit on voit
le laboratoire les vous avez une image
derrière qui est assez illustratif ses
laboratoires c'est un mélange d'eau
technologie est debout scotch et de et
de trucs un peu bricolé et je trouve que
c'est bien il arrive à produire cet
effet sur sur cette recherche qui est
toujours un peu intermédiaire entre
entre le bricolage et la haute
technologie et puis et puis voilà il
olivier est venu avec dark inverse pour
voir un tir de laboratoire s'inspirait
aussi et le personnage du staff qui
reviennent par exemple qui est qui et
pas le héros scientifique des films
hollywoodiens c'est un anti héros
il a cette espèce de fragilité qui fait
toute la toute la force du film et ses
essais ses les personnages qu'on croise
pour de vrai dans les laboratoires moi
j'aimerais bien que moyen que le cinéma
se penche plus sur ces sur notre domaine
qui a lutté pas inintéressant en termes
de sociologie aussi sur sur une forme de
compétition de ré brutale et en même
temps des gens qui peuvent être
totalement inspiré par par une courte
poursuite intellectuelle et puis à cette
idée aussi de s que abandonné la
recherche peut perturber sa propre vie
ou croisés disons des émotions qui sont
des émotions individuelle et personnelle
voilà donc c'était plutôt sur des
aspects là parce que sinon sur le reste
des poissons cette créature rose qui
intervient dans le film il l'a trouvé
dans la mer c'est avec lui qu'il va
parler c'est quoi cette créature est une
métaphore du pénis de gustave kervern ce
qu' elle lui ressemble un peu
franchement quand même moi je me suis
dit j'ai pas du tout pensé à ça pendant
l'écriture des films et mêmes jeux ça
faisait longtemps que je savais que ça
serait un axe au lot
moi ce qui m'intéresse chez lui c'est de
savoir ce que ce qu'on voit la cemac
cela c'est une création par ordinateur
ou pourrait le croire quand on voit
maintenant
non non il existe vraiment oui oui les
gens qui voient le film effectué
mon ceux qui le connaissent pas croit
qu'il est en 3d mais c'est un angle
istomin mexican home c'est le nom savant
qui est donc un amphibien est pas un
poisson en envoyant la rue dans son
milieu voilà dans son milieu naturel et
qui a des propriétés assez fascinante
parce que s'il perd un bras il va
pouvoir reconstituer son au 100 brasse
il perd un oeil va reconstituer son oeil
voire des parties de son cerveau et
aujourd'hui il est surtout utilisé en
laboratoire et vit plus dans son milieu
naturel et moi ce qui m'intéressait
aussi c'était c'est une espèce de même
ce n'est pas un poisson mais c'est un
être en phoebe qui sortent
il sort de l'eau avec des pattes et
comme une des théories de l'évolution
c'est que notre ancêtre était un poisson
qui est sorti de la mer j'avais cette
idée que dans ce monde un peu en train
de disparaître et bien il ya cet être
qui s'est adaptée qui a réussi à
survivre et qui ce qui ressort de la mer
et qui est peut-être un espoir du côté
du vivant nous on va peut-être
disparaître bon est ce que c'est si
grave mais il y aura peut-être à nouveau
une créature qui sortira de la mer pour
tout recommencer depuis le début et je
voulais juste te dire une petite chose
c'est que les poissons de parle c'est à
dire que je suis tombé sur des travaux
scientifiques
il ya une équipe à liège qui travaillent
sur le langage des piranhas et d'adam le
film gustave kervern il dit qu'il a il a
fait sa thèse de celui là jamais fini
son livre est en fait ils font des
craquements de mâchoire et et dans cette
équipe de liège a répertorié qui savent
dire casse toi dégage je vais te bouffer
j'ai envie de baiser parce qu'ils sont
forcément pas très poli les piranhas est
pas lisse en direct mais cette équipe de
scientifiques a identifié des démos
voilà et est ce que les enregistrements
de 200 de poissons qui existe et georges
de brega sais ce que c'est plausible
est ce que ce serait une éventualité à
laquelle on peut penser que les poissons
disparaissent
évidemment mais qu'ils cessent de se
reproduire ça ce serait plausible à
votre avis après tout on est tous
programmés pour faire des bébés qui
auront des bébés c'est la base même de
la révolution
il pourrait s'arrêter les poissons donc
dans l'est dans les faits des
perturbateurs endocriniens il ya
effectivement des effets sur la
reproduction
il peut même en fait les poissons ils
ont ils ont une formation d une
différenciation sexuelle qui est un peu
particulière on peut on peut forcer un
poisson en l'exposant à ce qu'une
substance a passé deux femelles à mal ou
plutôt orienté la différence sexuelle
donc évident est maintenant bien peuvent
changer
l'efficace et de la reproduction alors
ce qui est un peu différent dans le film
c'est que le poisson en fait il n'a plus
de désir c'est in and sorte c'est
presque un choix un choix personnel de
plus se reproduire ça je pense que ça
relève quand même delà de la science
fiction mais le le fait que la
disparition des espèces puissent passer
par par une perte d'efficacité de
dépression reproductif ça c'est possible
après la disparition complète de tous
les poissons telle qu'elle est vue là
c'est sans doute pas comme ça que ça va
se passer il va y avoir d extinction qui
peuvent être massive mais sans doute pas
de l'intégralité du chant marin on peut
l'espérer mais effectivement la
reproduction fait partie des fonctions
essentielles et si elle est perturbée
d'une manière ou d'une autre par
l'environnement ça peut jouer
massivement sur l'évolution des
populations à seulement pas
l'environnement parce que la question se
pose aussi pour nous et d'ailleurs le
film la pause à sa bannière mais est ce
que les êtres humains pourraient cesser
de se reproduire
on a souvent dit que les gens
intelligents se reproduisait de moins en
moins parce que pour les raisons que
vous disiez il trouve que le bond est
trop sombre et ses fonds et 10 à toutes
les époques
m'enfin grosso modo il ya un film
célèbre qui s'appelle idiocracy qui
montre que ça pourrait être les idiots
se reproduiraient à l'infini et en
revanche les gens intelligents se
reproduire est de moins en moins
alors est ce que est ce que n'ont pas
est ce que ça se confirme
mais est ce que ça vous semble possible
quand vous raconter cette histoire à la
route de la guinée et vous georges
daubagna penser que c'est possible
les humains ont cette particularité qui
peut effectivement faire un choix qui
est non naturelle je pense que le les
aspects sociaux étaient de poissons qui
conduirait à ce que certaines catégories
décide pour des raisons philosophiques
se reproduire construit des bornes et on
a peu de chances de le voir
donc je suis plus intéressé 2 parce
qu'il raconte plus que parce que je
pourrais dire moi-même là dessus mais en
tout cas visiblement ça vous inquiète
et quand on a vu le film on s'en
inquiète
je rappelle qu'il sort demain en salles
ça s'appelle poisson sexe s'est réalisée
par olivier babinet avec du staff
kervern et india m merci tous les deux
[Musique]
et on termine cette émission avec le dr
luke perry neuro vous êtes médecin
diplômé de médecine tropicale et
épidémiologie et d'épidémiologie un mot
qu'on a appris à prononcer ces derniers
temps et moi même je continue de
bredouiller en le disant vous êtes
l'auteur d'un livre intitulé patient
zéro c'est un livre qui est paru à la
découverte en mars juste avant le
confinement est malheureusement passée
inaperçue de bois en tout cas alors
qu'il est très intéressant alors
rappelez nous d'abord lu pérenno ce cas
pas sur 0 alors le terme patient zéro a
été créé au moment de l'épidémie de sida
par les années 1980 81 exactement parce
qu'on a découvert un patient qui à lui
seul est supposé avoir contaminé
pratiquement un tiers ou un quart des
américains pendant les deux premières
années du sida fait ce terme a été
repris mais n'est pas d'origine médicale
vraiment les médecins quand il parlait
dans le cas d'une épidémie et met sa
part les deux cas index
on disait le cas index c'était la
première personne qui était supposée
avoir contracté la maladie
on utilisait aussi ce terme de cas index
pour la découverte d'une maladie
orpheline ou d'une maladie génétique et
puis le terme de patients 0 a dû plaire
aux médecins puisque je prends cette
journaliste qui l'a utilisé la première
fois et les médecins l'ont repris ce
terme mais uniquement pour les maladies
infectieuses avec vous coupez mais il se
trouve que je le dis votre livre est
paru juste avant il a été écrit avant
l'avant la pandémie de kovy de 19
est ce que la question se pose
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on est ce qu'on
cherche le patient zéro duc vinh 19
évidemment on cherche toujours le
patient zéro de toutes les maladies
infectieuses depuis depuis qu'elle
existe
on a toujours cherché à savoir d'où
était parti et comment et est partie
l'épidémie
au moment de la peste recherché et quel
était le bateau qu'il avait ramenés
d'inde ou du moyen-orient
donc on a toujours cherché à connaître
la dynamique des épidémies évidemment
maintenant avec nos moyens
technologiques de plus en plus précis et
notamment avec la recherche génétique on
arrive à remonter à tracer le virus
passée la bactérie a tracé la première
personne qui a été porteuse de cette
virus ou de cette bactérie grâce à des
analyses en fait la technologie a permis
d'aller tout simplement plus loin donc
on recherche alors dans le cas présent
c'est très intéressant de retrouver le
patient zéro dans le cas du coc vite
donc puisque la vidéo question des vides
en ce moment en couvrant quelque elle a
été la mutation qui a permis de passer
de ce qu'on appelle de franchir la
barrière d'espèce quand l'appel ci a
permis à un virus de passer d'un autre
animal à un autre humain
hélas cette mutation en rouge ou pas on
n'a pas encore trouvé par contre à peu
près identifiée
les premiers patients atteints dans la
région dont alors effectivement quand on
cherche le patient zéro on peut se
tromper vous faisait allusion à celui
qu'on a considéré pendant plus de 30 ans
comme le patient zéro de l'épidémie de
sida on va le voir apparaître dernière
moi il s'agit de gaëtan dugas célèbre
enfin il est devenu célèbre le pauvre il
était stewart sur air canada était
homosexualité très beau comme on le voit
sur cette photo est sur les 250 premiers
cas de sida répertoriés aux états unis
un tiers parent est il avait été
contaminée par lui donc on l'a considéré
pendant longtemps comme le comme le
celui qui avait le super à fekter en
fait le super propagateur mais
aujourd'hui on dit que il ya très peu de
choses qu'il est était le patient zéro
il y avait forcément lui des gens est
certainement eu des gens avant
entre autres on a analysé ddd des gens
qui était mort depuis plus longtemps il
s'est aperçu qu'ils étaient peut-être
porte qu'un jury l'a donc on peut se
tromper et où quelqu'un alors que ça a
fait beaucoup de tort à ce jeune homme
mais qui malheureusement était mort de
toute façon mais à part ça ça ne change
rien que ce soit lui le patient zéro un
autre en ce qui concerne l'épidémie ça
ne change pas grand chose
j'imagine ça ne change rien non
seulement on faut pas dire qu'on s'est
trompé il a été considéré provisoirement
pour une pour l'épidémie locale nord
américaine il est certain qu'on l'a très
vite compris que l'épidémie était venue
d'autres pays et à force de remonter le
patient zéro par définition
il remonte toujours toujours en amont il
est toujours provisoire
un patient zéro est toujours provisoire
et là on est remonté très en amont pour
le sida puisqu'on est arrivé à
pratiquement avec presque une certitude
absolue bon on peut pas dire ça en six
ans mais de façon assez certaine à aux
années 1920 dans le combo ça pourrait
être ça semble être un virus simien donc
à virus de singe qui seraient passés à
l'homme par une blessure puisque la
contamination du sida est
essentiellement sanguine
donc il serait passé là donc on en est
là pour l'instant mais si les moyens
nous le permettre au matin on montrera
peut-être plus haut au moment du
franchissement de la barrière d'espèce
donc autres singes et humains alors dans
votre livre vous faites-le certain
nombre de portraits de patient zéro qui
sont tout à fait passionnant il y en a
un en particulier
c'est celui de denrées gustav molaison
on va le voir derrière moi c'est un
garçon qui a eu un accident de vélo
quand il avait 27 ans il a été opéré et
du jour où il est opéré il perd
totalement la mémoire alors n'ont pas la
mémoire de ce qui lui était arrivé avant
ses 27 ans avant son accident de vélo ça
il s'en souvient très bien mais il ne va
plus jamais se souvenir de nouveaux
souvenirs et et vous parlez de brenda
milner qu'il a étudié pendant 30 ans
tous les jours elle arrivait pour voir
pour voir henry du staff que les on est
tous les jours il lui disait bonjour
madame comme s'il ne l'avait jamais vu
et ça m'a forcément rappeler un film
amour et amnésie avec avec adam sandler
theft une comédie où une jeune fille
souffre en fait de la même maladie et
elle ne se souvient de rien ils veulent
art séduire tous les matins et je crois
que c'était une fantaisie pas du tout ça
existait alors le cas de h m on
l'appelait le patient h&m qui étaient
impatients adorable cas qui s'est soumis
à toutes les investigations de deux de
ses médecins
donc effectivement lui c'est encore un
cas un peu particulier puisque il a été
opéré parce qu'il avait une épilepsie
donc et il a été opéré et le chirurgien
à cette époque sur la neurochirurgie
était un peu débutants c'est très
barbare
on lui enlever tout ce qu on appelle l
hypothalamus hip hop hop on enlevait des
zones considérables et cette opération
j'allais dire a servi de test clinique
pour voir où se trouvaient les zones de
la mémoire en fait 2-0 grâce donc en
fait ce patient on a grâce à lui on a pu
trouver différentes étaient déterminés
différents types de mémoire est
effectivement lui l'avènement des
troubles très particulier puisque comme
vous l'avez dit se souvenait il y avait
les vieux souvenirs mais ne pointe pas
en enregistré un seul nouveau voilà donc
on sait que pour il faut l'hypothalamus
pour enregistrer de voile a donné
l'hippocampe du cerveau qu'on voit là et
là on voit bien que votre livre c'est
vraiment une histoire de la médecine
inversé on s'intéresse d'abord aux
malades qui a permis aux médecins de
faire la découverte toute façon pour
pour que c'est un livre que j'ai voulu
faire pour montrer comment se crée une
science et notamment la science clinique
et la science les icônes et très
complexes ont bâti une science à partir
du cas de deux personnes
et souvent on ne connaît pas tout ce
qu'il ya derrière le cas clinique
c'est-à-dire la physiologie et on la
découvre très souvent à ce moment là
donc là on a découvert effectivement un
peu la neurophysiologie de la mémoire
grâce à deux ou trois patients célèbres
il y en a d'autres que lui mais celui-là
a été le premier et puis j'allais dire
le plus spectaculaire puisque c'était au
départ une très grosse erreur médicale
chirurgicale fait spectaculaire elle est
également le cas d'oreillettes à laax
devenu henry est appelée vente par son
mariage c'était elle est morte à 31 ans
d'un cancer mais elle a connu une forme
d'immortalité on la voit là henrietta
grâce à ses cellules
c'est à dire que on est soixante dix ans
après qu'elle soit morte
la masse de ces cellules représente
plusieurs tonnes aujourd'hui répartis
dans le monde entier
ces cellules sont très particulières
elles prolifèrent à une vitesse et avec
une vigueur extraordinaire et on les
étudie quasiment dans tous les
laboratoires henrietta est devenu très
célèbre il ya des plaque à son nom sa
tombe et est constamment fleury on lui
doit beaucoup à oreillettes alex et
bien sûr alors c'est pareil c'est un cas
c'est assez extraordinaire elle avait un
cancer du col de l'utérus qui bon être
concert relativement fins peu grave
globalement généralement est le sien a
été foudroyant en fait c'est un cancer
foudroyant très rapide je pas si
importante
six mois après le diagnostic donc ça
c'est terrain on a d'eau prélevé ces
cellules sans que la famille le sache
donc son mari le sachet on a cultivé ces
cellules et ô surprise des cellules une
vie trop donc cultiver une vie trop la
plupart des cellules humaines ou
animales que qui avait une vie trop
meurt après les chaînes donc les lignées
cellulaires meurt après quelques
semaines mois et elle est sans jamais
morte
on a trouvé des cellules immortel
effectivement alors ce qui est assez
amusant c'est que les médias ont titré
en titre et on a trouvé le gène de
l'immortalité à ce moment là alors que
c'était précisément des cellules qui
avait tué une leur patiente donc c'était
plutôt le gène de la mortalité très
rapide et donc ces cellules ont été
utilisés vendu elles ont utilisés pour
des expériences pour des vaccinations
notamment le vaccin antipolio elles sont
allées dans l'espace la nasa
et puis beaucoup plus tard la famille
s'est rendu compte que cette cellule de
leur mère de leur grand mère
vous connaissez aux etats unis c'est
toujours compliqué toujours des procès
avec les ai finalement maintenant cette
table est reconnue et sa famille à à
partie par une fondation et les cellules
d'henrietta lacks sont en effet toujours
vivante cultivées en usine en usine
maman s'est pas seulement est utilisé
pour beaucoup d'expérience puisque alors
il ya le cas d'auguste deter auguste
d'acteur c'est une femme au début du 20e
siècle
elle a une maladie que son médecin va
appeler la maladie de l'oubli
et son médecin il s'appelle aloïs
alzheimer est en fait c'est la première
malade d'alzheimer
c'est là on se dit que pour un médecin
c'est un sacré coup de bol il est là il
est dans un centre à francfort il reçoit
cette femme si le mari de cette femme
avait amené sa femme de 41 ans de 51 ans
à l'époque dans un autre hôpital on
l'appellerait pas la maladie d'alzheimer
mais la balle a dit de celui qu'il
aurait reçus c'est là où on voit
l'intérêt mais nous reste très peu de
temps il serait qu'on termine non papa
avec auguste deter mais avec marie
malone alors marie malone elle est quand
même fantastique on va la voir
apparaître cette femme en étant 19 cents
à new york elle se fait engager comme
cuisinière dans une famille aisée de de
manhattan pas de chance toute la famille
à trappes la fièvre typhoïde
elle perd son travail elle en cherche un
autre elle devient lingère elle se fait
engager dans une autre famille très
aisée elle aussi à manhattan
pas de chance la famille tombe malade
elle oscille à pied fièvre typhoïde et
il va falloir attendre un certain temps
pour qu un épidémiologiste et schilb et
d'aller voir my mind et de lui dire
dites moi vous auriez pas la typhoïde
qu est ce qu elle lui répond elle lui
dit non évidemment puisqu'elle se porte
très bien
voilà alors ce cas est doublement
intéressant surtout en ce moment parce
que c'est la première fois qu'on a pu
faire la preuve qu'il existait des
patients au porteur de bacilles ou de
virus dangereux et sans avoir le moindre
symptôme le le grand coq le grand
infectiologues allemand donc celui du
bacille de koch avait dit il est
possible que ces graves maladies que
l'on craint la tuberculose le choléra la
typhoïde soient apportées sans aucun
symptôme par des patients mines on
n'avait pas la preuve grâce à mary
madden on en a eu la preuve ça c'est
très intéressant on appelle le porter
seule le problème pourtant il ya
beaucoup y avait beaucoup pour toutes
les magnifiques pour toutes les maladies
mais la première vraiment connu
cliniquement repéré cliniquement saïd et
marie malone pour est disponible qui est
une maladie très grave comme vous le
savez beaucoup plus grave que celle que
son histoire et son histoire est encore
plus particulière vous la raconter en
détail c'est que après conduit fait
faire des examens elle s'en va elle
change de nom elle continue de
transmettre la typhoïde
elle va quand même donné la typhoïde à
cinquante et une personnes en tout cas
celle qu'on a retrouvée et en tuer 3
la pauvre et à la fin
qu'est-ce qu'on fait d'une femme qui
toute sa vie va transmettre la typhoïde
et tous les gens qu'elle approche
eh bien on va la condamner à perpétuité
au confinement et là aussi on est dans
l'actualité
elle n'aura plus jamais le droit de
sortir de l'institut et les journalistes
qui viendront la voir se tiendront loin
loin belle avec l'interdiction absolue
de d'accepter de sa part qu quoi que ce
soit à venir vernon nine président voilà
ça a été un premier quart médico légal
où on a finalement offert mais
impatients une patiente qui n'avait rien
cette grave rien d'illégal et on ne
refait pas malade qui n'était pas du
tout mal à zagreb
elle est morte j'allais dire presque à
elle est morte d'une autre maladie un
problème vasculaire cérébral et il avait
toujours le bacille ifrit dans ces
véhicules qui n'avait jamais donné le
moindre symptôme c'est amusant et
peut-être mais toujours bien vivant en
mêlent bien nos chers une irlandaise
solide et bien en chair merci luc perino
patient zéro histoire inversé de la
médecine c'est édité par la découverte
est un livre passionnant
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]